what do you remember about being on
Smallville
that was so fun now she had fun that was
great fun everybody knew their lines on
that am I talking to you are you someone
that never knew their lines is that no
no in fact that's one of my biggest pet
peeves is when people don't know their
lines and I always have to know them
inside out so a lot of times if they say
you know what I don't like is the night
before they say hey first up you're
gonna do this scene and we just rewrote
it that's that couldn't be more
terrifying because I'm just as stressed
as you can be yeah I want to that's why
I'd rather do a movie yeah or rather do
a series where you're about to shoot
that they have it all written yeah and
you can prepare and know your stuff it
just makes such a difference it makes
sense you change lines up it's it's not
a good thing but um Smallville you did a
couple episodes three episodes I did
three was it three or something yeah
I had a great time what do you remember
we didn't work together I don't think so
no I mean we did kind of an iconic scene
of putting the baby Julian Sands and I
putting the baby into the rocket to like
go bring it down to and then with yeah
everyone was so kind on your set do you
remember that I loved them all it was a
family it was just true it really was
there wasn't anybody I didn't like
working with no and they were so sweet
to me and very you know I felt very well
that's what it's about if the hardest
thing and I I'm repeating myself is to
be a guest star and when you come into a
a place where everybody has it down all
their jobs they know what they're doing
and you come in and you're the
you know my friend Kathleen wilhoid says
she says being a guest star or a guest
director is like being the girlfriend at
your boyfriend's family Thanksgiving
okay it's like you're going you're kind
of welcome there it's not your family
it's not your thing it's still testing
you but you don't you do we like her
yeah yeah is he gonna marry you who did
you work with mostly
Tom and Tom and I had a little bit with
Laura Vander Laura vanderboard Supergirl
Andrew she was Supergirl yeah yeah and
but it was Tom and Julian it was Tom
though in that third second or third I
can't remember it's too long ago it
hasn't been that long ago hasn't I think
so
like 10 years ago 15 years ago I should
remember that long what year yeah
something like that what year was that
Ryan what she was on Smallville okay
because you know we're doing the I told
you we're doing the smaller rewatch
podcast I know it sounds very so
everybody listening is going to be like
you have to have her on oh you have sure